what's happening there reject nation just greg
today here because everyone i know has seen this
movie john has seen it multiple times and i've
gotten a lot of flack for never having seen it
and that is the movie forrest gump starring thomas
the hanks yup the time has come for this long
epic film i hope i hope i like it after after what
everyone's always raved about but uh guys as usual
thank you to the super sexy rejects for showing
your support to us over the years full-length
watch alongs for forrest gump will be over at our
patreon page along with a bunch of other things we
cover as well many of those shows have reaction
highlights included as well but if you can't
do that please leave a like that would be very
much appreciated also subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified for when our
next movie reaction is up got a lot of things in
the pipeline actually so excited for what we have
in store for 2022 and then boys at prepper thank
you for helping me edit down these highlights
couldn't do it without you let's get into it
alan silvestri marvel zone composer alan silvestri
this feather flying through multiple stories of
lives and i'm trying to pick
up thematically what it means
oh you know it's funny i had a plaid shirt
looks like that i almost wore that one
see my name's forged forrest gump do you want
a chocolate never take candy from a stranger
my mom always said life was like a box of
chocolates you never know what you're gonna get
those must be comfortable shoes my feet hurt
well i'm always saying there's an awful lot
you could tell by the person buy those shoes
very true that's why we're ferragamo mama said
they'd take me anywhere you can open your
eyes now let's take a little walk around
oh now when i was a baby mama named
me after the great civil war hero
general nathan bedford for us he
started up this club called the ku
klux klan oh my god and act like a bunch
of ghosts or spooks or something what
and anyway that's how i got my name oh god
he's gonna have to go to special school he's
not going to some special school to learn how
to retread ties we're talking about five little
points here is that mr gump yeah this is gone
oh god oh your mama sure does
care about your schooling son
you don't say much do you eh
one time a young man was staying with us
and he had him a git talk case oh here we go
i was just showing him a thing or two
on the guitar here that's supposed to be
actual elvis it sounded good
oh my god he invented elvis's dance
moves this one night me and mama was
out shopping and we walked right by a bench
he's running to an appliance store guess what
and here i was thinking that all of us it was
appropriate black culture taking advantage of
little kids are you coming along thomas
enough to be taking rise from strangers
this is a busted school i'm forest for skunk i'm
dorothy harris well now we ain't strangers anymore
what a good heart kid i do remember the first
time i heard the sweetest voice in the wide world
you can sit here if you won't i had never
seen anything so beautiful in my life
i just sat next to her on that bus and had a
conversation all the way to school like a question
mark these are going to make me next to mommy no
one ever talked to me or asked me questions are
you stupid or something stupid as a stupid noise
i've heard that she helped me learn how to read
and i showed her how to swing she's not doing
anything you're doing man just run away for us
run
hear some of the things you've
like heard in passing before
oh [__]
oh damn forest unleashed the forest awakens
that's some touching ass [__] dude
that day on if i was going somewhere i was running
that's so cool she lived in a house that
was that was alabama her mama had gone up
to heaven when she was five and her daddy was
some kind of a farmer he was a very loving man
he was always kissing and
touching her and her sisters
oh my god are they implying what i
think they're implying did you hear me
who in the hell is that and they as
far as gun coach and can you believe it
i got to go to college too
no way
gosh really makes you want to exercise
way to go for us
stop stop running man president kennedy ordered
the secretary of defense then to use military
force hereby videotape is the encounter by
general graham commander of the national guard
and governor wallace because this movie's
more mature than i expected it's been
ma'am you dropped your butt man so you wouldn't
have gum no that couldn't be sure as hell was that
when wallace got shot i was in
college it was co-ed cause jenny
went to a college i couldn't go to but
i'd go and visit her every chance i got
oh you got to be [__] me jenny
oh brought you some chocolate i'm sorry i'll
go back to my college now forest oh for a guy
have you ever been with a girlfriend i sit next
to them in my home economics class all the time
damn jetty you've been so far with him
since you were like little little kids man
they put you in this little room with just
about anything you'd want to eat a drink
and since number one i wasn't hungry the thirsty
and number two they was free i must have drank me
about 15 dr pebbles my god congratulations
how does it feel to be an all-american
very good sir congratulations how do you feel
i got a pig i believe he said he had to go pee
that's pretty good technology man after only
five years of playing football i got a college
degree congratulations son mama was so proud
first i'm so proud of you dude she's aged like
40 years hello i'm forrest forrest gump how about
you give the husky [__] who you are boss ball
it's your [__] ass on the bus
you're in the army now saints titan
tight oh what's up god damn meet
this guy my name's forrest gump
people call me for skunk so bubba was from
biola battery alabama and his mama cooked shrimp
bubba i'm going into the shrimp and business
for myself after i get out the army okay
your sole purpose in this army to do
whatever you tell my drill sergeant
god damn it trump your goddamn genius that's
the most outstanding answer i've ever heard
your nets along the bottom on a good day
you can catch over 100 pounds of shrimp
everything goes all right bubba
gum shrimp is pineapple shrimp
lemon shrimp coconut shrimp pepper shrimp shrimp
soup shrimp stew shrimp salad he found the perfect
friend to listen to him let's give a big round
of applause to the luscious bobby dylan from
hollywood california huh her dream had come true
she sleeps in the sand she was a folk singer
go punch that man you can't keep doing this all
the time i can't help it i love you oh we prayed
for god to turn me into a bird so i could fly far
far away you think i could fly off this bridge
damn jetty's life is so goddamn
depressing they sending me to vietnam
this is whole other country
just if you're ever in trouble don't try
to be brave you just run okay just run away
okay and just like that she was gone this poor guy
so simple-minded where you
boys from in the world alabama
you twin
no we are not relations
try and keep your feet dry when we're out
humping i want you boys remember to change
your socks whenever we stop me calling the leader
grunts feet right off his legs sergeant sims god
damn it where is that sling rope i told you that
kind of miscarries denise man you're cool actor
trying not to do anything stupid like getting
yourself killed i sure hope i don't let him down
he seems like he's on some sort of spectrum
right doesn't quite strike me as directly autism
could just be simple-minded hearted and we
were always looking for this guy named charlie
one day it started raining and it
didn't quit for four months wow
i even wrote jenny and told her all about
it told her how i thought about her always
and how i was looking forward to getting a
letter from her just as soon as she had the
time damn what a different path just like that
somebody turned off the rain and the sun come out
whoa whoa whoa
oh my god i ran so far so fast pretty soon
i was all by myself which was a bad thing
bubba was my best good friend i had to make sure
he was okay oh god no just leave me here get
god i up leave me here god damn it then it
felt like something just jumped up and bitten
i got an airstrike inbound right now
they're gonna need the whole area
don't you stay here goddammit
that's an order i gotta fight bubba
i will never be as good of
a person as this guy oh god
okay forest i'm okay
oh no that's his best friend
really good effects i would
rather put that together
what just happened you got shot i want to
go home bubba was my best good friend oh
it was a bullet wasn't it it jumped up and [__]
they said it was a million-dollar wound but
the army must keep that money because i
still ain't seen a nickel at million dollars
it's time for your bath lieutenant
oh [__] come on i'm forrest gump
tuttle
oh man i thought this was a
feel-good movie what did i walk into
now the secret to this game is no matter
what happens never take your eye off the ball
so i started playing it all the time i played
ping-pong even when i didn't have anyone to play
ping-pong with ping-pong is so fun i gotta get a
ping-pong table the hospital's people said it made
me look like a duck in water whatever that means
cool you cheated me i had a destiny i was supposed
to die in the field with honor that was my
destiny and you cheated me out of it god damn it
do you understand what i'm
saying gump so heart rate
president johnson awarded four medals
of honor to men from each of the armed
owes you a debt of gratitude son
i understand you were wounded where were you hit
in the butt talks uh oh that must be
a sigh i'd kind of like to see that
streets was awful crowded with people
looking at all the statues and monuments
and some of them people were
loud and cushy okay follow me
everywhere i went i had to stand in line
oh my god is forrest gump going to do lsd
yeah yeah so psychedelics first there was this man
giving a little talk and for some reason
he was wearing an american flag for a show
his name was charlie manson well there's only
one thing i could say about the war in vietnam
she keeps talking
that's it that's all i have to say about
that that's the right on man you said it all
she showed me around and even
introduced me to some of her new friends
shut that blonde man and get your white ass away
from that window don't you know we in a war here
in the middle of your black panther party
we walked around all night
jenny and me just talking
she told me about all the traveling she done
and how she discovered ways to expand her mind
we have very different lives you
know i want you to have this oh
oh i can't tell if she views
him as a big brother or
you know more fluctuates so i was in the special
services traveling around the country cheering up
all them wounded veterans and showing how
to play ping pong the army decided that i
should be on the all-america ping-pong team
when i got home i was a national celebrity
famous or even in captain kangaroo uh here he is
forrest gump right here i'd watch a whole movie
about him playing ping-pong man people hardly
got nothing at all no possessions they never
go to church no religion too ah hard to imagine
well it's easy if you try dick some years later
lieutenant dyn said he was living in a hotel and
because he didn't have no legs he spent most of
his time exercising his arms i stayed with
lieutenant dane and celebrated the holidays
gary sinise is so good in this
movie have you found jesus yet no
i didn't know i was supposed to be looking for
him before you go why don't you get your ass
down in the corner and get us another bottle of
red yes sir your neighbor like has alcoholism
gary sinises resentment in their conflict is
so good but in the middle of all that fun i
began to think about jenny wondering how she was
spending her new year's night out in california
coming sharon stone from casino poor
woman just abused her whole life man
daddy's your friend's stupid
story don't call him stupid
hey don't you punch him yeah shut
up don't you ever call him stupid
oh no
there's some great effects
come on forest start up the shrimp
business give them a purpose
a few months later they invited me and the ping
pong team to visit the white house so i went again
well where are you staying it's called
the hotel ebot oh no no no i know of a
much nicer hotel it's brand new very modern
i'll have my people take care of it for you
send a maintenance man over to that office
across the way the lights are off and they
must be looking for a fuse box or something
because in flashlights they're keeping me awake
thank you good night oh my god
therefore i shall resign the
presidency effective at noon tomorrow
your career will be ruined or
you'll die around forrest gump
i have your discharge papers
service is up son discharge
you have an age a day since he went off to join
the army i took mom out to a real fancy dinner
and i bought a bus ticket and three dr peppers
tell me something are you stupid or something it
is super does i love it putting all that on gas
ropes and new nets the brand new shrimp and boat
he did it for us go hire lieutenant dan now
i haven't heard from jimmy in a long while
but i thought about her a lot and i hoped
that whatever she was doing made her happy
damn she's gonna od isn't she
oh [__] no way
wow i thought she was really gonna do it
showed up
what are you doing here well thought i'd try out
my sea legs well you ain't got no legs lieutenant
well well captain forrest gump
i had to see this for myself
i told you if you were ever a shrimp boat captain
that i'd be your first mate well here i am
yeah yeah but don't you be thinking
that i'm gonna be calling you sir no sir
still no shrimp lieutenant day okay so i
was wrong well how are we gonna find them
well maybe you should just pray for shrimp
he's like drax
hurricane carmen came through here yesterday
destroying nearly everything in its path wow
only one shrimping boat actually survived
the storm wow after that shrimping was
easy since people still needed them shrimps
for shrimp cocktails and barbecues and all
we were the only boat left standing bubba
got shrimp's what they got bubba gup forest
never thanked you for saving my life
forrest had a phone
we sure call you straightened out didn't we boy
i forgot that was the same doctor i didn't
know it but i was destined to be your mama
i did the best i could you did good yeah great
so i i never went back to work for lieutenant dan
he got me invested in some kind of fruit
company and so then i got a call from him
saying we don't have to worry about
money no more and i said that's good
fruit company i gave baba's mama bubba shea
she didn't have to work nobody's
catching them all awesome
and then she was there all right
i'm ready to marry you now jenny
came back and stayed with me i did all the
talking jenny most at times was real quiet
nightmare home how can you do this
god
i had no idea that her story
would be so goddamn heartbreaking
him is this one constant good thing in
her life and she even showed me how to
dance then he became a worldwide famous
dancer and well we was like family
jenny and me i hope she does not leave
i swear to god man will you marry me
i'd make a good husband jenny you don't want
to marry me why don't you love me jenny oh man
she take it off so i ran to the end of the road
and when i got there i thought maybe i'd run to
the end of town president carter suffering from
heat exhaustion fell into the arms when i
got there i thought maybe i just run across
greenbelt county this is the best nike commercial
for no particular reason i just kept on going
i ran clear the ocean santa monica
i figured since i've gone this far
i might as well just turn back keep right on going
you're gonna need some glucosamine
for those knees man so you just ran
there's a nice sense of adventure to this makes
you want to explore a little bit a man named
a gardener from greenville alabama stopping
only to sleep has been running across america
they just couldn't believe that somebody would
do all that running for no particular reason
why are you doing this i just felt like running
i mean it was like an alarm went off in my head
you know i said here's a guy that's got his
act together here's somebody who's got it all
figured out here's somebody who has the answer
i followed you anywhere mr gum
i had run for three years two months 14 days and
16 hours i'm pretty tired i think i'll go home now
oh man shh could have been at
something so i went home to alabama oh
poor people putting their faith in one day i
had a blue clear sky i got a letter from jenny
wondering if i could come down to savannah and see
her and that's what i'm doing here what's going on
henry street is just five
or six blocks down that way
everything works out for you whoa
it's weird seeing him off the bench
i want to apologize for anything that i
ever did to you because i was messed up
this is my very good friend mr gump here can you
say hi to him hello mr god it's that haley joel
hussman his name's forrest like me i named him
after his daddy he got a daddy named forrest too
you're a daddy forrest wow there's nothing you
need to do okay you didn't do anything wrong
it's the most beautiful thing i've ever seen
is he's smart he's very smart he's one of
the smartest in his class looking so sad
i have some kind of virus and the doctors
don't they don't know what it is and there
isn't anything they can do about
it would you marry me first okay
oh oh what no way you got new legs titanium
alloy it's what they use on the space shuttle
magic legs
oh no
hey are you scared in vietnam sometimes it would
stop raining long enough for the stars to come out
that was million sparkles on the water beauty and
the struggle you died on a saturday morning mama
always said dying it was a part of life
yeah and every night we read a book she's
so smart jeffy you'd be so proud of him
i am oh my god damn each have a destiny
or if we're all just floating around
accidental like on a breeze maybe both is
happening at the same time yeah i miss you jenny
if there's anything you need
that's a really heartbreaking i know this
i'm going to share that for so-and-so because
brandon used to read it to you
my favorite book feather fell out
good movie man
i know buddy been in here a while
let's just chat about it all right here we are
forest gump gump finally talking about forrest
gump it's weird i kind of had this identity as the
guy who had never seen forrest gump in circles i
always loved the expression but you've never seen
forrest gump now here we are it's funny watching
this because um i would constantly hear the the
rhetoric would change over time about this movie
in random circles i would run into i'm sure
if i looked up an article online it would
tell me all the reasons why forrest gump is a
problematic movie now because i would hear that
and not knowing what the movie was had
no real basis other than just that word
problematic i didn't know why today there would
be things about that are considered problematic
there are things i can venture to guess
why some might consider it problematic um
but that's not my job to sit here
and try to dissect it i'm not here to
do some video essay about why for scope is
problematic you know like there are some things
i might say in passing as i'm talking about
it uh but all i have to do is just tell you
how what my feelings on the movie are and i think
it wears its sentimental heart on its shoulders
very well like it's such a fantasy movie that
whatever might be considered problematic because
it's a story about i i don't know if this if if
he's supposed to be it seems the movie strikes
me as like he he's on the spectrum of some
sort so it doesn't ever outright declare he
is doesn't ever say he has like asperger's or
autism or something like i don't i don't know
if the movie was actually doing that after a while
i'm like he's probably just a simple-minded guy
you know with a great big heart and
to me the movie was more about that
because he's kind of coasting
through life through most of this
with just naturally accumulating some of the
greatest world experiences with such simplicity
that i like that i really appreciate that
quality of it so much because he's surrounded
by terrible things like he give us the freaking
vietnam war for crying out loud uh the woman he
loves for verse for eternity is is down such
a temperatureless path and while he might be
blind to so many things he's surrounded by racism
for crying out loud and so if i were to guess
really quick if i were to guess why people
might consider this problematic today
i'd i'd have to say it's because of the political
angles that people might draw from it because this
movie while covering political american history
events it doesn't really seem to be about politics
to me it's sort of the backdrop of the experiences
but it's more of a commentary on humanity
yeah i probably i i i'd probably
just go that way like you know he's
picks up the book at the college for for the black
student who is getting accepted into the into the
school um even when the black panther person's
talking to him it's kind of played like a joke
and he's not really doesn't really seem to be
taking it in so a lot of like the the messages
about racism that you could probably do to make
this more of a powerful impact to really have
something to say the movie doesn't really seem
too interested in that it seems more interested
in just exploring the the simplicity of life that
you can go about it in a way that doesn't have to
be as complex and still lead something great and
to be appreciative of what's in front of you and
in the present moment as well like there's a lot
of qualities to this forrest gump character who
it's interesting like i i wonder if this
role had come out today if this would have
gotten tom hanks the oscar because it's a really
it's in a lot of ways it's it's not i wouldn't
call it one note that would be very unfair
to call the character one note um he's just
so simple and then his emotions seem to
kind of hover between like happy sad and
misunderstanding like a misreading of a situation
you know he takes everything so literally
and and i like that about him
i really like that because
while it's at times it might read as like a
really simple performance it works so well for
the movie because he's always just about doing
what he feels is the good thing we're doing
the right thing or doing his duty you know just
going through life and and following his feelings
and following what he just believes in the moment
he has to do despite how other people might try to
read it as something more at times you know it
might just be just because and as simplistic as
that is there's something about that i find really
fascinating to watch and also i don't know i guess
i don't really get offended by any of the things
that might be lacking in something that could be
a true heavy like social political commentary
it's in such a fantasy world like this this
movie i didn't know that going in like it's such
a fantastical world but it but imbued in real life
you know and like using historical events which
i thought was a really nice nuanced touch to have
this jenny character that threw me for a loop you
know at the beginning they imply the sexual abuse
from her father and how having had having not
overcome that it has created a ripple effect of
lack of vulnerability attachment issues escapism
like she just goes through this cycle of abuse
for the rest of her life and never truly coming
in terms with it it doesn't seem until she like
has a kid so i don't know if there's something
problem i'm gonna do caught up in it it's just
that was the other voice that was in my head the
whole time of why do people think this movie is
problematic now because i thought the movie was
actually really sweet and and it was so much about
love you know like i i thought robin wright's
performance was really good and i really liked
um the performance by gary sinise i thought was
actually my personal favorite in here i loved his
whole character arc you meet him at the moment
where it's like prime lieutenant dan you know
this is what he does he's part of the jungle he
knows war and he is ready to die honor the legacy
of his ancestry of everyone who died in the great
american war before him and he felt like he was
destined for that and even though forrest saves
his life he resents him for that action because he
doesn't know how to appreciate his own life but by
being closer to forest and being friends with him
and watching his life change he finds plenty
to be grateful for and then finds love
i think it's [__] like that that what the
movie is really about is yes there's a lot about
persistence and even though he's
often met with very little struggle
sometimes we get in our own ways i think that's
an interesting commentary about humanity is
sometimes we complicate things ourselves so much
this is a fantasy world okay and it's not the real
world but in life i'm saying that sometimes
we do get in our own heads way too much we
oftentimes our biggest obstacle is just within
it's just ourselves and we have to overcome that
and as someone who does not register obstacles
the way how other people do he's able to kind of
lead more of the life that other people often
desire because he's surrounded by people who
are struggling constantly you know like the moms
and dad it has to sleep with the principal to get
him into school gary sinise jenny obviously very
very tough lives everywhere he goes it seems like
everyone's kind of having like a tougher life than
he is and i think that's part of the inspiration
of this character is you know i'm trying to go
back to what it must have been like to watch him
for the first time of i wish we more of us could
be that way everyone's like always searching for
such a purpose you know where him he he looks for
adventure without really thinking like that he's
just kind of going with the feeling like when
he decides to go run across the world for three
plus years and how he creates this following
of everyone who's trying to add more meaning
to what he's doing when he's like no i just i
just wanted to whenever when a lot of times we
try to make things more profound than what they
really are and maybe there is more to dissect
of why forrest gump the character made that
choice that he might he might not even be aware of
what i thought was really cool about the way that
was handled was like every one of the journalists
were just like what are you doing this for
they're all listing a bunch of different
political agendas that forest could be doing this
run for that it's symbolic for something deeper
and it never was for him it was like
a an instinct i can imagine there's an
emotional route to it like he's going
through pain and this is his way of
working it off in some ways this is you know jenny
escapes maybe this was his way of escaping uh but
it's not to try to he's surrounded by messages
all the time and political agendas all the time
throughout his life as as most of us are and
yet it was always about finding the simple way
through it all you know something that oftentimes
is like very black and white thinking friends are
in danger in vietnam i gotta go save them despite
what everyone else is saying i should do run don't
run very very simple way of thinking and i keep
using the world the word simple because that's
i guess i was expecting to walk into a movie that
was going to be like so heavy on messages and
so deep and in a lot of ways it's deep in
a way that is not as complicated or or as
complex as i expected it to be and i appreciate
that about the journey because it's like it
touches on subjects and terror like especially
with the jenny character like it touches on so
much and then there's like the war violence that
is so much more mature than i expected it to be
because he is like a child in a in
a grown man's body going through
life and surrounded by adult situations
and everything seems kind of foreign to him
i guess i'd consider it problematic if the
movie outright declares like he's an autistic
guy because i think the way movies often
portray autistic characters is not always
uh good like normally when the characters normally
autistic characters are portrayed in movies it's
it's like they're they're math geniuses or some
[__] or like they solve like the alien rubik's
cube of life or some [__] and uh yeah they're
always like you're secretly a genius yes if it's
a power to use it and uh i'm curious because i
thought it was based on a book and i don't know if
the book would declare that he directly is um but
they don't really lean into that too much like he
was still able to just see him as a as a guy who
just views who has just a sim keep using the word
simple like i'm beating that word to death here
he just has a really easy way of looking at life
and doesn't get in his own way too often
he just goes about it he is like a soldier
running through life and as so i think like
him going to war is very apt for the character
because as a soldier through life he's
just following what life is telling him
to go follow and i think that is so cool because
most of us don't do that and i think a lot of us
find success in in many areas of our life
when we're least thinking about the end result
of things you're just focused on the
moment doing what you have to do and then
naturally you might accumulate some things that
eventually lead to success or fact you just don't
know most of the time and i really like it i
don't know i thought it was a really sweet film
i thought it was something that was um very
moving very emotional and had a great heart
and i just i thought the uh well the song was
from the freaking early 90s so while some of
the visual effects are a little bit wonky i
think for the most part they hold up pretty
well like they would be so much better today
they would do like full-on defects or you
just get some cgi actor in there really
really match the words of the mouth but
as it stands i still think the visual effects are
i think the visual effects on like jerry sinise
who obviously has his legs in real life like the
way they handle it when they were amputated and
the way he moved around that looked really good
too i was very much i i found that very marvelous
and this this whole movie seemed to
have this message of just kind of
i don't know i guess it
would be about appreciation
like i like the montage at the end
when he's talking to jenny about the
you know the experiences he's had with um you know
doing that a long marathon for those years but
the the landscapes he saw the sights to behold
or when he was struggling at with the with the
bubblegum who was struggling with capturing the
the the shrimp and and looking at the the sky
even in vietnam uh uh how heavy the weather
was and how much endurance it required
yet that it was like the the reflecting upon
it was always about the beauty that was there
it's something i really struggle with personally i
it's really easy to say look at the silver linings
and be grateful for things it's really really hard
it's really easy to get caught up in circumstance
and it's something i really
really have a hard time with
and uh it was nice to just sit back with a movie
that's kind of like no appreciate it fazel's
still badass still beats this [__] will smith's
everyone who [__] threatens his woman it's great
so yeah i liked it i'm not sure what
to make of the jenny and forrest gump
relationship honestly if there's one
part of me that at times might rub me
the wrong way and i'm not even sure how
to articulate it right now is um just uh
like forrest is just so forgiving and
tolerates uh so much of the way uh he's treated
by her with so much of like just keeps banning
she keeps abandoning him and then has a kid
that's his kid for so many years and doesn't
ever tell him about it and it's just like
it's it sometimes it can read as it's easy for her
to take advantage of that hit and knowing that he
is going to be a constant who is always there for
her despite however much how despite the fact that
she doesn't seem to fully give herself over the
way how forrest does so she she can go off and
have these crazy life experiences and sleep with
all these people and whatever like that's not the
part i'm like critical of it's more of the there
are parts of it that do feel like yeah you kind
of take advantage of the guy a little bit though
you know you think about it he does choose to just
stick around and wait for it so you know it's his
decision ultimately um but that's kind of me just
sort of reaching in and thinking of something that
could that that wasn't actually really bothering
me in the moment um but yeah as it stands glad
i finally saw it that was a really good movie
i didn't quite love it to the heights
that people maybe have built it up to be
um and but i can imagine that the more i think
about it the more i'll really appreciate this film
so yeah either way thank you guys
for being here i'm glad i kind of
us have some laughs and tears with you all uh very
very moving film and uh i'll talk to you guys soon
now nothing but marvel
content for the next six days